everyone happy not sure what today is I
think it might be Wednesday I am pretty
excited because I'm heading off to see
Jenna and she had Maddie last night she
was dog sitting for me basically because
she missed the puppy and I had to go to
dinner so I said you know what if you
want to take him have a sleepover at
each others house
hi I just took an accidental nap I mean
it wasn't technically an accident
because I did go to bed it was all
intensive taking a nap but the length of
the nap money tube in the external part
I did my hair still what Jenna just
asked me if I took a shower and to which
I answered what considered you take a
nap to me yeah they did have a sleepover
just Restless the entire night I printed
email Oh what do we do about it
oh you do smell Wow you call him your
son or your boyfriend they want you to
make up remover oh I wrote back to them
and I said it wasn't that Moe's
relationship I saw okay good I see
everything she does that's my shirt
here's the dilemma that I'm having Jenna
I might have made a bad decision by
getting the Mac Pro because it sold my
computer upstairs doesn't work Jen
what's the new one there isn't anyone
yet it's the thought of a potential new
one when the new one comes out probably
the thing open it up open up they can't
return it
actually a few guys what do I do do you
eat the back this is what I told myself
if you buy this computer there's gonna
be no more complaining that you can't
edit videos and you have to pose a tech
Tuesday on actual Tuesday and a cooking
video on Thursday you think that's cool
huh
whoa if I just keep sitting around
waiting for the next bus can you come on
I'm just gonna be sitting around the
step yeah are you gonna go to the store
to thanks maybe we done this like what
do I do
what do you think about already but
let's just open it and see this is okay
honestly I'm gonna have them decide if I
keep it or not I'll use this knife yes I
will I'm just gonna look at it
problem is I also know that they are due
for an upgrade that's crooked goodness
when this was first announced I remember
I had one of the Mac Pro to max out the
RAM hard drive capacity and everything
and that was all nice one other crisis
right so I didn't ate the time need this
one I'm completely maxed on my laptop
because I have able to know on that and
I've heard so many loops and plugins
that it can't even do anything so I want
to put Ableton on this Matthew this is
how we do general you want to come here
real quick and see what's up just come
here I'm your mom keep it I'm gonna need
you to keep me on my toes and every
Tuesday and Thursday they don't close
the video
we will do do I wait you I don't wait
play make up your mind buy a theory of a
deadman thinking 2002 theory of a
deadman so decision lies in your hands
and if I do decide to keep it guess I'll
do an unboxing for you don't let us know
what you guys would like to see us cook
I've got a special video coming out
tomorrow it's with the row from nerdy
nummies it's a video that I think a lot
of you guys have been waiting for for
quite some time it's pretty incredible
Alexa what's the weather right now in
Los Angeles is 64 degrees and 3
tonight's forecast calls for more of the
same
with a low of 57 degrees so worrying
about me I'll be fun ok I'll see you
guys later peace
happy Wednesday hey guys how's it going
so I've been doing a little bit of
research about the new iPhone 7 there's
been tons of rumors out you guys have
tweeted me a bunch of things so I
thought that I would just go through and
look at some of the rumors and making a
chat about it together in the comments